les cas d'abus
à
si si
aussi qu'est ce que je suis venu pour
tous et onext du butin
voilà
mais l'événement il est ici ce soir et
les doigts tous pas vos potes c'est la
chanson que vous allez tous chanté
pendant la coupe du monde
elle est énorme alors j'ai eu des
propositions sur le titre de votre
chanson hashtag apatow l'apollon qui dit
bédard hymne national donc ben haim
nationale voilà un renfort
il ya quelqu'un qui lit pape en mai un
coup franc le titre c'est quoi le titre
c'est on va la [ __ ] au fond là je suis
sur twitter qui me l'avait elle avait
presque alors c'est une exclusivité
c'est la première fois que vous l'avez
bien sûr jamais fait une petite maquette
qui avait un petit peu tourné mais trois
fois rien il a du coup je me suis dit je
vais pas rester le cul vissé à la casbah
la coupe du monde arrive tous les ans on
a eu droit à une chanson merde autant
que je la fasse moi même alors juifs
vous deviez pas par des danseuses elles
vont arriver vous inquiétez pas et vous
allez voir
elles sont mignonnes ah ouais ouais
j'avoue
ouais bon ben alors pour général une
exclusivité pour touche pas à mon poste
vous pouvez louer le volume écoutez bien
c'est la chanson de la coupe du monde de
sébastien patoche ça s'appelle donc on
va [ __ ] au fond je la connais sachez
que je connais déjà par terre la coller
mais n'a pas faire c'est parti
je vous entends tout le monde tape
éléments attention
on n'est pas des meilleurs
c'est prêter direction rio et rai 2 et 3
0 on va passer pour des balades parce
qu'on a si l'édile zidane ait plus bas
on s'en fout on va leur faire le coup du
chapeau à tous d'en faire un coup dans
l'eau et 6h fini au penalty on s'en fout
on abattit ni ajout pu non plus moi
c'est pas grave parce qu'on a la [ __ ]
au fond on va
au fond si on est bon et qu'on descend
du bus on va la [ __ ] au fond on le
fout
nous sommes
on
pour
toi le gardien et car chez cuisse qu'on
marque un but on
outre fo pierrot on va la [ __ ] au
fondre on va la [ __ ]
au fond si on est bon et qu'on descend
du bus
l'afutt rançon oui on va [ __ ]
au fond on va la foudre ont fait
toi le
carrick mais ce qu'on marque un but pour
le porter
aulas
bon
oh
là
merci c'est un battant 24h patoche
catastrophe
bravo et peut-être alors et elle a dit
tout ce que vous en pensez sur twitter
mash up pour je suis à fond mais parce
que possible merci
huawei